l'explosion elle arrive en fait après
une heure ou une heure et quart de
visite extrêmement mouvementée h et
jacques chirac essaye d'avancer parfois
la police tu dis monsieur le président
on n'avançait pas parce qu'il ya
peut-être des terroristes ici il ya
peut-être des terroristes est ici
jacques chirac dit continuer à avancer
veut absolument serrer des mains on sait
que jacques chirac était un grand
spécialiste de la poignée de main est
visiblement il voulait serrer la main à
tous les tous les palestiniens qu'il
allait rencontrer à jérusalem est
mais c'est pénible ça dure longtemps à
chaque fois policiers s'interposent
parfois il faut jouer des coudes et
parfois même le président lui-même
repousse des policiers israéliens c'est
quand même une situation très baroque
pour une visite d'état d'un président de
la république
et puis soudain il explose parce qu' il
s' et le x6m incident parce que pour la
deuxième fois un soldat lui interdit de
progresser et donc ils appellent le chef
de la police me souviens bien il avait
des lunettes noires il suffisait un peu
ses gardes du corps qu'on voit dans les
films ces terrains et il le pointe du
doigt et il me lance le fameux la
fameuse expression en anglais do you
want me to go back to my plein do you
want me to paris c'est à ce moment là
que nous les enfin son époque j'étais en
agence de presse où on se dise si on
assistait ce qu'on appelle un incident
diplomatique donc on va envoyer on en
voit ce qu'on appelle une alerte ou un
flash et un quart d'heure après toutes
les télévisions enquêter en poste à
jérusalem et américaines les anglais
arrivent dans la vieille ville pour
filmer la suite de cette visite qui sera
encore mouvementée pendant pendant une
bonne heure jusqu'au
au mur des lamentations en passe d'en
bas la mosquée al aqsa ou d'ailleurs
jacques chirac n'a pas eu le droit
d'entrer il y avait encore un mur de
deux soldats israéliens
et ça s'est terminé terminé donc au mur
des lamentations mais tout ça a duré
deux heures
c'était mouvementé et surtout on se
demandait mais qu'est ce qui va arriver
est-ce qu'il va y avoir d'incidence qui
verra coups de feu et éventuellement
tirer dans la vieille ville et dans ce
cas là qu'est ce qui se passe